today's episode is brought to you about
gray block pizza gray block for when you
need pizza they got it you know
sometimes you have you you need to have
a skill and you don't have time to go to
college dude how long does it take to go
to college four years and you probably
have to knock a chick up oh that's
hectic now there's something called
Skillshare it's basically a place it's a
learning platform actually it's not a
place and it has over 20,000 classes in
business social media design technology
marketing you can take all those classes
right there on Skillshare so whether
you're trying to you know get deeper
into your already you know already you
know real crevasse II skill set or
rather you're just trying to learn
something new
Skillshare has it think about something
you can't do right now and suddenly you
can and that's what Skillshare does for
you so join the millions of students
already learning on Skillshare today
with a special offer just for our tpw
listeners get two months of Skillshare
for just 99 cents that's right
Skillshare is offering tpw listeners two
months of unlimited access to over
20,000 classes for just 99 cents go to
Skillshare comm slash Theo th EO that is
Skillshare comm slash Theo man what gets
me is I'll get in my email and I'll be
just trying to respond to something you
know respond maybe my aunt sent me a
picture or something or you know she
always takes pictures the wrong way at
birthday parties right in with the
window in the background so all the
sunlight is there and it's not even cool
pictures she sends and but those are
still emails that I want to reply to a
lot of other emails I get are all types
of Groupons from Russia things like that
people want me to invest and you know
glitter mining all type of shady stuff
but now you can get rid of all those
crazy emails in your inbox and that is
with the same box same box so you
respond to only the important things and
the messages that truly matter same box
features the same black hole where you
can drag messages from annoying centers
that you never
want to hear from again ever again uncle
Gerald showing me pictures of those ice
cream pops boy you being wild
never again see how SaneBox can
magically remove distractions from your
inbox with a free two week trial visit
SaneBox sa ne bo XCOM / theo today for
your free trial and receive a $25 credit
that's sane box.com / theo and when i
think a sane box I don't think of my
ex-girlfriend your knowing on today's
guest is a man who actually that book
Van Wilder was based on this man and he
is uh you know when you think about a
man I mean I bet if you just cracked
this bad little piece of human cattle
open I bet his colon smells like Miller
lights and he's a special kind of man
and he's a family man he's a comedian
he's done some really wild stuff in his
day and he was once voted the number one
party human in America as a child as a
semi adult child and he's not an
alcoholic but he's you know well I
probably shouldn't have said that part
of this but he has a new special coming
out on Netflix called secret time and
he's here today my friend mr. Bert
Kreischer
[Music]
I've done this a lot my life I was
thinking about this Abed lot like I take
liberties with people that I think I
know right and I make a joke and they're
like and because I'm not a ballbuster
I'm like I just hang out guys people
think I don't like them and I go no no I
[ __ ] love you I just thought like you
break my balls I can break yours and
right that's all yeah yeah yeah I feel
you Whitney Cummings was in here we were
all I had the same thing happen or
Whitney are the exact like like I did
this thing where this was breaking balls
I didn't know and I put it it gets me so
upset because I go I like I like you I'm
you're my friend like I'm doing this for
fun but I we went to a Rams game and you
if you do
hashtag mob squad your picture goes up
on the methane Jumbotron and so I
remember the scene you got on the
jumbotron I got on the jumbotron I'm all
over the Jumbotron whenever you go to
that game I'm like the first nine
pictures because it's the most likes get
up on the jumbotron yeah there's one of
me with a bunch of chicks and I got the
machine on my first point of that yeah
and so as a joke I'm with my buddy Tony
and we're [ __ ] up and I'm flipping on
Instagram to see if I'm up on the
jumbotron and there's a picture of
Whitney with our horse and my buddy goes
oh my god wouldn't be [ __ ] hilarious
just screen grab it post as if it's on
your account hashtag mob squad and it'll
go up on the jumbotron and so I do it it
goes up on the jumbotron and just the
row behind or someone goes who the [ __ ]
brought their horse to a game and we're
laughing hysterically and then you know
Whitney just it's just out of context
and she's like the [ __ ] is he making fun
of me right I'm like no you're my friend
oh my god then you feel horrible and
you're like and you're like I just want
to call you and go cuz the text doesn't
work the way right but yeah I do that to
everyone you know you can't do it to
Bill burr these are the ones I do it to
where it says total safe place and maybe
I should just stay there Segura Bill
burr Rogan re Joey even with Joe you got
to be a little careful because in Joe
because Joe is not the most
technologically all over the map guy
right he just hears word-of-mouth
Gilbert was [ __ ] on you he'll call
you immediately yeah but like Joe man we
[ __ ] with Joe Hardy [ __ ] on that still
Brock tober thing yeah oh yeah when he
was doing
I remember he came in and Kevin the
congressman said he seemed kind of like
upset I was like what's going on he's
like I've had to do yoga for 30 days let
me tell you let me tell you something
about [ __ ] Rogen and by the way well
just because of these internet goddamn
trolls I love Joe Rogan he's one of my
closest friends but man when he when we
started doing that hoe of October thing
this is how it went down okay it was all
about me
everyone's gonna do it but then Ari and
Tom said they'd be into it and and we
thought it was a thing a collective with
Joe so I cut this video and in the video
it's me running through the forest and I
go this sober octo so October me and my
friends - titty Tom are either well
Shaffir and Joe and powerful Joe Rogan
we'll all be one sober I send it to Joe
before I post it and I go hey just
making sure everyone's cool with this
Joe didn't reply right and so we're like
he took that as he ya know so cigar and
Tom and I are like sugar and Noreen are
like wait with no reply from Joe oh and
then our he's like weep Joe's doing it
right so he sends a text and Joe's like
no [ __ ] you guys I don't have a problem
you guys [ __ ] suck you guys are doing
it and then our ease then our amounts of
[ __ ] attack campaign I think any
texts us independently he goes yo I'm
taking down Joe you are with me now
sucker is such a [ __ ] [ __ ] even when
we [ __ ] write or he's like I'm gonna
post a video I want your comments to be
the first two comments on Instagram huh
and I know we're gonna workshop them so
they're aggressive enough that Joe has
to reply right
so I write mine I guess I really don't
have a problem Joe's got the problem he
can't give up marijuana whatever I said
you know he needs it to eat his dinner
if you need marijuana eat your dinner
you've got a problem and this the girl
right sister is such a [ __ ] [ __ ] he's
like he's like powerful Joe Rogan
doesn't need to give up anything he's
the greatest human being in the world
whatever the [ __ ] you said it was like
that right right aryen are like no [ __ ]
you
we're writing yours yeah and you're
cutting pasting it you're not leaving us
out to dry right so we I wrote Tom's
Senate sorry and it was with the hashtag
pray for Joe Wow and that pray for Joe
went [ __ ] viral like it's on the end
of my special on the end of my special
that like who would you that want to
thank and I wrote I want to thank -
titty Tom the Welch and hashtag pray for
Joe and the crazy thing was that you go
to hashtag pray for Joe if there's
also tons of like people that have been
hit by cars named Joe and stuff like
that who are in all these like hospital
beds and then there's Joe Rogan no like
the Dalai Lama so it's okay it's a
really wasn't really caught up in there
I went to the pray for Joe hashtag one
time and end up spending like probably
almost $2,000 in GoFundMe campaign no
dude I can't even I don't know what to I
don't blame you it's I'm telling you man
and I we know I think one of the things
people enjoy about that sober October
and about these bets that me and Joe and
Ari and Tom make is that it sets up the
joke for them to join along and they can
make fun of the comics they love like
Joe or Tom or Ari or even myself hmm and
then and they know that we get it that
we know it's a joke right and so and
they make us laugh and then we repost
good ones and people are like you're
people come up with me and greets but
like bro do you remember the the picture
where Joe was up front and you and Ari
were in Vietnam and Joe is it was
Apocalypse Now and I was like yeah and
they're like I made that you're like
total [ __ ] dude and I we follow a lot of
those guys like Photoshop Steve oh sorry
guys there's a lot of really great
artists out there that we all just got
into because they make awesome [ __ ]
photo shops dude Adi Brock's Diab rocks
there's a man there yeah there's a
conflict follow them all because
whatever they post the ones with Talia
the guys that [ __ ] with Talia make me
laugh least Eric oh do when I go on the
road and I get videos with stuff of
people it's always like [ __ ] Talia all
of them dude [ __ ] Rapoport
he's someone when he lost his belt to me
they have a belt right here that I won
wait how do I get the belt you hey you
have to win it okay you didn't win it
Minova how do I win it uh I don't know
oh so it's like they kid I'm going on
fire in the kid like couple weeks I
talked to Brian and okay so what
listeners in just vote right okay and
but here's the thing though I didn't you
I didn't do any campaigning so there was
just like that was the thing it was like
you let their listeners vote and I feel
like their listeners just voted and I
beat Chris D'Elia by like this was last
year by like thirty one percent to
thirty percent or something Hinchcliffe
had one percent even though he campaign
like a [ __ ]
we also has I feel like he has by the
way roses but he just manages that
really
well you notice that if I gotta be
honest with you if someone can get this
up I know this I'm the only one that
sees this
Tony hunts Club today looks like Joe
Rogan in 1991 no I swear to [ __ ] god
there's a picture where Joe is in a
leather jacket and he's off to the side
and he's like this and their jaw lines
there this jaw part is identical this is
pre kettlebell Joe Tony Hinchcliffe
could go as Joe Rogan for Halloween I
bet I hung a over from Newsradio I don't
know even then Joe is getting a little
yoke but Tony has like the very here's
like to [ __ ] like uh Tony has like
somebody who's been who was trapped in
like a mine or something and finally
made it out like but years later and
everybody like they thought everybody
had died in there whatever they built a
neighborhood on the mine and everything
and it's all over and Toulouse even
forgot about it and then Tony comes out
like it a chameleon like literally he
had a rock climb from a million feet
like he was the first of the the Thai
soccer team kids yeah he's the big one
yeah dude Tony's got that that that
little brother strength where you like
you go into the house and you think
you're like oh I'm bigger than I'm gonna
[ __ ] him up and then you go and [ __ ]
with a little brother but he's been
being punched so much by the big kids
yeah all sudden he's like [ __ ] to the
nuts Kong oh my god
your little brother doesn't fight fair
tony has a look ivy look at her and Tony
[ __ ] roasts him the other day so he's
getting this back right now where he
looks like he's holding the devil in his
mouth on him you look at him he's like
this like the devil is living right on
it like the devil is resting on his
tongue and he's just he knows it's in
there he doesn't want to show it to you
you know
oh the Badger the feeling when we text
each other and you just don't hear my
response yeah and you're like dude I
[ __ ] pissed them off oh I send
another text and these someone were
texts you don't have a wow we're
touching fruit Justin Harry and David
dude my freaking uncle got a piston I'm
Harry and David no there was gay fruits
from a gay man's farm yeah it up it
might be its payers they're good do you
don't think straight men can grow these
kind of pairs have you see had I ever
had him know Harry and David Lakers they
just make pairs I mean yes if you're
broke right
the only [ __ ] cookies delivered I see
the cookies I got the cookies I also had
the apples from Oreo eeeh vertebrate
Nabisco those dude when I was in college
we had this this do that work for
Nabisco his name was cuz and he always
show up with all the destroyed products
cases of Nutter butters like I got to
the point where I got stuck to be a such
an aficionado I would take the Nutter
butters and I'd put them in a in a
cabinet and let them get stale there's
nothing better than utter butter yeah
Oh soft Jew yeah it's almost like a
brownie oh I would take Nutter butters
and I would dip them in melted chocolate
right but I'd leave just enough area
space so that I could open so I could
soak them in milk so there would be it
was almost like a soft milk cookie
inside chocolate mmm do we this dude in
our neighbor named dirt this dude Mert
everybody called him dirty Mert right oh
let's do this let's go neighborhood for
neighborhood about white trash
[ __ ] this will be fun as [ __ ]
well start myself but I'll go dirty Mert
do this do dirty murder so he would get
Nutter butters and different types of
cookies right he would let him get you
know to the point with some of them
crumble now some of them if they're
really not a good cookie like I uh
sometimes a chocolate chip cookie will
get bad and then it'll fall apart yeah
that's a piece of [ __ ] yeah
that's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] that I
didn't have any but there's nothing in
it you can't do that with the really
like the soft batch ones you got to eat
them right away right like Nabisco the
the Chips Ahoy I mean it's it's middle
ground middle ground but man but
sometimes you get one but here's what
you do if you go all the way around this
dude Mert would go all he would let him
get soft and then let him ride the
[ __ ] ride the empty you know just
ride the empty tank all the way back to
[ __ ] heart and you were like wow they
were a different color then I know then
they had gone a different color they'd
gone down the color scale and they were
called these [ __ ] dirty Mertz and
this dude have a whole sack of them and
he [ __ ] give them out and we ate them
any
whay bruh we knew how long they'd been
out and about and wherever he used to
leave a [ __ ] rower remember this now
he had a like a Buick like a like some
type of a Buick or Crown Vic or
something he would leave him like in the
[ __ ] heat on the back of his [ __ ]
car almost like he's oh my god you know
my wife's family that's how they used to
cure meats they put it that up I swear
to god they put meats and it's no wonder
this your wife in know my wife's fantasy
this is really [ __ ] redneck like why
discipline your dog with a shovel
redneck oh yeah like the kind that
you're like hey my mother hit dogs
anymore they're like how you gonna learn
they would put meat and fruits inside a
old beat-up like that they definitely
have cars everywhere in their front yard
and backyards right there cars
everywhere my her father I'm not even
joking on his property he may have a
hundred and fifty broken down cars boats
he collects outboard motors mhm and he's
got he's got a short storage shed of all
the [ __ ] from when she was a kid
just on his property but they used to
put fruits and meats inside the cars in
the summer let him dry out that way
beautiful redneck right there that's
[ __ ] beautiful dude a little bit of
that [ __ ] back deck jerky boy Oh and
then like you whenever you go to like a
family reunion they'd have Cool Whip
containers it was how you did
instead of like like nice yeah okay we
quit an entertainer and you're like oh
your mashed potatoes are in a coolant
container I know they've grandma and one
of the grandmas would be like I don't
wait thankou dude the first time I ate
dinner I ate at their house this is so
what made you wanna being your wife will
you guys just total just [ __ ] out of
the gate or like what was the whole deal
there ya know my wife my wife was your
wife's a beautiful lady to manage I
spent cameras are very sweet she's great
she's great I started she didn't get a
real short haircut did she no okay and
that's something that doesn't cause a
lot of couple start to look the same as
they get older and if they're still
[ __ ] and they're not you got a that
to me is there something else is going
on no no it's like they're just trying
to make one person as hard as they can I
had sex with a girl a day this grown
college
got her all her hair got a pixie haircut
and we're having sex and as we're
[ __ ] I'm drunk right now as her
[ __ ] I went he's like [ __ ] a dude
and I was like woah woah woah yeah I was
like whoo well that's a buck um I met
LeAnn and we dated for a little bit I
didn't put a label on it and then she
dumped me
mhm and then when she dumped me I fought
to get her back I made her a mix tape I
did everything what else do you do every
thought do you mean honestly Oh try
I was crying or driving down there like
you poppy flowers no I'm [ __ ] crying
okay I made salt water with my eyes I
went to an AAA meeting I did everything
I went to a meeting
dude I gotta say a meeting and they're
like and I'm with this guy I guess I
shouldn't say his name but he's like
he's like you should stand up and talk
and I was like I was just lost man I
wanted this chick back Wow what did you
say this is great cuz I go to a meeting
so what do you say if you so they go um
I love this was like alright I go I
don't know if I feel comfortable talking
I don't really made any decisions about
what I'm doing in my life I'm just
trying to like get this chick back and
see if I have a problem because the
reason we broke up is I gotten drunk at
a dinner party and I just argued with
her friend and I wouldn't let it go and
so I could see that and so uh he goes
yeah I just talk I'm like okay I'm gonna
talk and part of me is a comic I'm like
yeah I gotta get up it's a little staged
time as a bad guy in front of me I love
it there I go to get I gotta stand up
right and then the guy in front of me
stands up he goes do you mind if I go
and I was like oh sorry yeah go ahead
he stands up and he goes hi my name's
Dave or whatever yeah I'm an alcoholic
and everyone's like hi Dave he's like
it's been a rough day oh this morning my
landlord came over and I sucked his dick
and then I lit his car on fire oh my god
and I was like I can't follow that yeah
I was like I can't let somebody else go
I can't go right after that I'm gonna
[ __ ] eat a bullet up next guy you're
like this is the Chris D'Elia of a
meeting so I didn't say anything left
and I was like I was like I don't know
if that's for me and then and then like
the next day I wanted a jog down Outpost
I came running down outpost on to
Franklin I live right over by Hollywood
Island and I and I was I was like I
don't know what
you were out here when you met your lady
oh yeah yeah yeah and I was like I don't
know what's wrong with me I feel like I
I don't I was like I really don't feel
like I have a drinking problem I really
don't feel like by going need to stay
sober for a while get my head straight
if I'm gonna be single I need to figure
out what I'm doing with my life and I
had this a moment that I spoke to God
God's and I think God said if you want
her back he's just got a promise that
she's the one and you won't [ __ ] it up I
swear to God I spoke to God no idea and
I was like I go I'll never [ __ ] this up
just give her to me and I will never
[ __ ] it up I'll marry her and this will
be my chick this is the one for me he's
like I remember him saying in my head to
me mm-hmm remember who just said I got
home and she was in my bedroom on my bed
and she was in a sundress and she goes I
think we need to figure out how to what
was she doing in there she had just gone
to church she'd gone to a church down in
Compton cuz she's Baptist and you come
on up here and she'd gone to a church in
Compton and and in church someone had
said to her in her head you need to get
this guy this guy's a good guy he needs
a second chance Wow
and so then we just we hung out we had a
great time didn't party for like six
months it didn't drink for like six
months and then one day we're in Italy
it's New Years Eve and it's snowing on
Venice it just starts snowing I'd [ __ ]
you there that sounds beautiful and I
said I said to her I said I gotta be
honest with you this is what I want to
drink is like it's snowing we're in same
you drank for six months six months I
didn't drink and I didn't have a like
that's other problems I don't have a
problem quitting drinking like I almost
have a problem starting up again right
it's so like I go I don't I just feel
like I Shh I want a drink and she goes
honey I don't think you've a drinking
problem I have a drink well we had a cup
we had a but we split a bottle of wine
went out in the snow in st. marks it was
empty it was [ __ ] empty was like the
day after New Year's Eve town is shut
down and it was [ __ ] gorgeous st.
Mark's st. Mark's is a big square in
Venice it's like just huge and it was
just starting to snow it was like
perfect snow everywhere I was [ __ ]
great and so yeah I've been with her
ever since but then she got nervous cuz
she's like okay I got to introduce you
to my family first thing she said was my
dad my dad lives in a convenience store
okay
and I was like a CES they call him I go
okay and she's like I just want you to
know like you know like my family's from
very humble means yeah I was like
alright sure enough is called Kemp's
corner and it was in Bowden Georgia and
we pulled up about owing bowd oin no
bowd and Wow
and walk into a convenience store with
all your luggage right like how [ __ ]
weird you walk into like a convenience
store with all your luggage and then
walk into the back and put it in the
back and we hung out there went out to
eat came back and the he closes of a
convenience store and we're sleeping in
the freezer right pitch-black no windows
ice cold a love it's like a cave yeah
and the Milman like right before bed
he's like did you guys want anything
like a snack before bed and I was like
yeah you just walk into a convenience
store I got like a [ __ ] 40
I got a Snickers bar I got some Reese's
peanut butter cups I was like this is
[ __ ] just murdering food I was like I
think I love you I think I need to marry
you I'm gonna get you pregnant first
your redneck you understand yeah yeah
man that's a seaman first it's dude you
gotta see if that [ __ ] chick will
play yeah can't take her to the game not
known if she can pitch yeah and did you
guys when do you guys start making love
or you'd already been making love who
know we don't even make yeah we we had
sex probably like five dates in this
back to her Sex in the City
remember that Sex in the City run we're
all guys thought all girls were [ __ ]
mm-hmm
I remember thinking that that will just
even looking on Instagram so there was a
period where women were like and that
thing is still there but like Sex in the
City came out and when we're like yeah I
like to [ __ ] oh I could see that and now
we're in control of our own [ __ ] and
that scared the [ __ ] out of me cuz I'm
only have sex with six people women why
am I saying people what woman [ __ ]
adult women too don't women or all the
women you ever had sex with over the age
of 18 yeah Wow yeah even my first one
when I was 17 was 18
[ __ ] yeah do play baby she was a senior
lay up dude yeah JV dude getting up in
the bigs huh yeah and I dated a chick
younger than me when I was 18 and I
never [ __ ] her because I this is gonna
sound so creepy that I would have this
wherewithal but even then I just didn't
think it was right so I was like she's
younger than me
she was like a junior hmm I was a senior
I was 18 she probably 16 set maybe 17
and I was like I'm going to college
and I don't think that's right to do to
someone is take their virginity and just
[ __ ]
yeah yeah that's not cool and I never
had sex with her Wow yep
shout out to Jim Bethea Jim hey what if
she showed up now do you think your wife
could give you a pass she's married to a
guy that I [ __ ] really respect but no
she's smoking and what if something hey
Jim Buffet is gorgeous to this day what
if something happened to that guy if
something happened to both our wives and
me and her ended up like say we're all
now a cruise right and and it's like the
end of infinity Wars like half the
people just died yeah that's me and Jen
I still wouldn't know no she's
complicated
I love really one of my close friends
but but what she's just a complicated
person she is yeah she can [ __ ] work
she can work you in a spiral oh she's
great though yeah but yeah I don't I
mean I don't know I know her too well is
like I've known her for almost like a
little sister well my whole life now
because after that I went to Florida
State then she moved out to LA she was a
stylist for a while Lily yeah she's
great and you saw her again you got you
were dating your lady here with your
lady you have known her date when I was
dating my chick I've known her she's
dated a couple of my friends I love her
but like I couldn't man she's she's way
too much have you and your wife ever
thought about like doing swinging or
anything like that not even remotely
Lily that's so not LeAnn LeAnn Oh Liam
barely wants to [ __ ] me yeah let alone
other people huh yeah I think she's got
a crush on you though really yeah she's
a lot she loves you man she's a lady you
she took a shine to you and Schumer but
the two people she really liked well
let's talk about real let's talk about
reality bites back because that's where
you and I first met each other which is
kind of crazy like some people don't
even know about this show and I wish I
don't know if we could put clips of it
into this episode without it getting
taken down dude if I I'll tell you right
now if you could find the clip of me
getting kicked off of reality bites back
yeah do you remember that Greg Louganis
dude I'm great and Michael Ian Black
yeah do you remember what how I got
kicked off I remember you did like yeah
you were somebody said you did like a
DNA like like a broke chain D like an
HIV kind of DNA hit pants on a desk yeah
I've got there was it so for those who
don't know it's a reality show within a
reality show and I don't know where you
can find it if you can find this clip I
have all the videos at home please send
it to me I would love it and I'm gonna
make it sound ridiculous this is exactly
what it is
me mo mandel and Amy Schumer on the
final table hmm I have been hitting on
Greg Louganis the whole time as a joke I
thought it was like and he was handsome
I mean this is back tell you by the way
can I stop it with a pin in this your
dive in the wheelchair
hey Amelia or art was the funniest
[ __ ] thing in the world
thanks man I'll describe it for anyone
who can't see it
Theo does this like song to the judges
about Amelia Earhart makes no sense yeah
get to the wheelchair someone rolled you
off correct someone rolls him off and he
falls I think 25 feet 20 feet onto his
stomach yeah with what I think wings
attached to your wheelchair and and
knocks the wind out of him legit yeah
hops up like and we are all like fooling
me Earhart like a lily Earhart and
everyone's like 10 10 10 it was [ __ ]
amazing
and then mo mandel oh yeah oh did it
mimmo's dance Mose dive there's the
whole thing was so you think he could
dive it's a mix-up so you think he
danced and a diving competition yeah mo
man tells was making fun of the time
when Greg hit his head and I even think
he said there's aids in the pool or
something yeah he goes oh man I'm gonna
jump in the pool and I'm I hope I don't
get any aids on me or something then he
jumps and almost hits the diving board
which is [ __ ] it for real
unbelievable and he did not plan on
doing that at all I literally came 1/2
inch from hitting his head on the diving
board yeah and I remember what Amy's
dive was but it was inconsequential yeah
because and mine was everybody else had
already kind of [ __ ] there were so many
outliers that Amy almost has had a play
right in the middle yeah and and and and
Chris Fairbanks did a double flip yeah
and nobody gave a [ __ ] yeah get this
[ __ ] guy out of here but it was like
every so he plays made so many poor
choices oh and then and then so then
then the whole thing is then that it
turns into the board room with Donald
Trump whatever that show The Apprentice
yeah the pressure they bring us into the
end they bring me Amy and Mo in and it's
Greg Louganis and Michael Ian Black
and he real quick cruises through MO and
Amy's like mo your dive as well
offensive Amy it was inconsequential
Bert I understand you're married and I
want I am I think with children and I
said I am and he goes you're not a gay
man and I went no and he was like do you
realize how offensive it is to hit on a
gay man and lead him on and make him
think you were gay
I was legit hitting on Greg you again
it's the whole [ __ ] episode like even
low-key hitting on him even when the
cameras were off I was fighting with him
Wow thinking like if you think so you
know whatever right if he thinks I might
be able to [ __ ] my Pat give me an
extra you know yeah and he was like and
and I think it was edited out but I
think at the thing I go Greg you have
AIDS I would do you think I was hitting
on you and he was like he was like
you're fired
and he just gets up and leaves and Amy
and Mo are like oh my god they're like
what the [ __ ] did we just witness and
then they're like mo and Amy are
dismissed
and they get up and they walk out and
then Michael Ian Black goes Bert you've
made a lot of bad life decisions by the
way he's Mike's the Michael Ian Black
Sun even joking at this point right and
I was like yeah and he goes your body
your hair I mean facial hair like he's
picking me apart yeah I'm like yeah and
by the way I no joke I am humiliated at
this moment because I had driven all of
us down remember I drove us all down and
in the car ride down Amy said oh my god
what if one of us gets kicked off how
awkward it would the drive back be and I
was like oh my god I got to drive
everyone [ __ ] home
and so I he goes Michael Ian Black psych
oh I'm gonna need your trunks
your suit and I was like okay and so I
get up and I'm just embarrassed and I'm
trying to make it funny and I don't know
how to mmm so I knock over each of the
chairs and he goes what are you doing
and I said I make big exits Michael and
he was like no there's no music playing
in this Mike Lee and blacks yeah I mean
really talented kind of a [ __ ] though
but he's and he's really straight his
whole thing was like straight man yeah
always and I take my robe off and then I
take my trunks off and I'm naked and
he's like wow he's like and he might be
O'Mara he's not even joking at this
moment he's like I wouldn't do that by
the way there's a 30 person film crew
there yeah filming this I get on the
table and I put my feet on the back of
his chair and I start pulling his face
into my junk and he's like no no he's
like I go look at it Michael and he goes
I'm afraid I'll turn to stone
no part of you will yeah and then I
don't know and by the way I'm not
winning a laugh it is awkward it is
uncomfortable at this moment and I look
at him and in the lastest ditch effort I
kick and I do a back spin naked and I
stick it on the table and I look at him
and [ __ ] thank you Michael in black
breaks character and starts laughing
hysterically and the whole set starts
laughing and I walk off now my daughters
were in preschool at the time and I had
only been bragging I will be on Comedy
Central and I know now as I'm driving
you guys back that's all these parents
will see his mean face [ __ ] Michael
Ian Black
yeah oh my god and I tell my wife
neither dad's will be jealous probably I
tell my wife when I get home I see she
was headed today to go and I said I
think I might've just ruined my career
and she was like really and so I didn't
think about it until an episode aired
and then Amy called me the day there and
I was in Pittsburgh wow what did she say
she goes I just watched the episode
where you got kicked off it is [ __ ]
hilarious
you have nothing to be worried about it
is [ __ ] hysterical she's like
highlight of the show and I was like oh
thank god why it's funny and it was
funny and then it disappeared nobody
really have AIDS regular games cuz yeah
yeah these HIV positive I'm right HIV
positive positive yeah yeah do you think
you could be eight what's a disease you
could be name three diseases you could
beat honestly Crohn's
oh no way I think so you couldn't beat
crunch can you bring up Crohn's what it
is it's just your stomach hurts a little
bit yeah dude you're talking about a guy
who just like yeah we're [ __ ]
somebody in a deep freezer eating a
[ __ ] snicker and a forty no no way
you're know so you're talking about
beating the disease so you're talking
about me getting it and going I can lick
this disease yeah I could be Crohn's
which right around the but it's like
irritable bowel syndrome almost yeah I
can be Crohn's okay
I can be friends and by the way I'm not
to be flippant if you have Crohn's you
look you've no idea the hell no no no
super plate we're [ __ ] around
everybody but I'm not joking I changed
my lifestyle stop drinking start eating
healthy and smoking pot every day I
think I can I can manage Crohn's
I think I got managed crime you just did
a triathlon they just did a triathlon
yeah if I here's the thing once I get a
disease all I got to do
clean my lifestyle up and I
I think I can deal with it okay two
other diseases you think you could be um
hmm with some with your eyes optimum
optimum I could definitely Optima what
is that I think that's a word this is
getting better yeah I could beat the
gout easy
yeah Gattis that's just shrimp you know
too much shrimp yeah not enough elbow
movement um but it affects millions
across the [ __ ] across the south
I grew up in the gout belt dude
everybody at Gao everyone's got gout
back in Tampa dude red wine and [ __ ]
saucy shrimp yeah you're fair your
people owe half a [ __ ] family's like
crustaceans barnacle on your back and
like not [ __ ] had a salty salad a
couple years ago and it's never been the
same
it's crazy how salt just will get stuck
in your body dude when I like no joke
when I get my heaviest it's like when
I'm on the road doing like if I do a
theater run I kind of balloon up because
I'm flying and partying every day like
fly perform party fly perform party and
that's when I balloon up and I'll come
home and I'll be like 240 and then just
all eat healthy for two days and I'll
drop 15 pounds immediately of just water
weight I'm just cuz that you eat like
[ __ ] in the airports you drinking booze
you're retaining water
you're on planes your ankles are bloated
yeah and then all of a sudden just I
always think like if I just built fences
I'd be in great shape really like just
built fences are like oh really yeah you
don't think you'd be there
cuz look I used to work in that type of
labor force or not I mean it's so easy
bro to become this to do that [ __ ]
naps in the truck dude it's so easy to
be that dude okay I'm on you're right
I'm wrong I'm the Napper oh yeah what
the [ __ ] am i doing what the [ __ ] am I
doing here I got confident with Crohn's
and I started saying [ __ ] I could do no
I couldn't do that you're right you're
right cuz I'm the guy that if I was
building fences and they were like hey
man we're gonna burn one behind the
house I'm in I'm in next week you know
him in the back of a bed of a truck with
my head on the hammer going oh yeah yeah
bills here let's get back to work yeah
it's so easy to book like all it takes
is one long lunch and next thing you
know you're that [ __ ]
one long lunch where they go in and they
pull in the store and the guy in front
of you your head your head chaperone
you're a guy yeah great so grabs a 40
just a tall boy is a work and he were
working hard and suddenly the next thing
you know you're Rodney King never Rodney
King when he was on a celeb celebrity
worked for like some housing company and
he worked for a pool company really in
in Compton Terry basil worked with him
didn't he comedian yeah Harry basil that
runs the Laugh Factory they just show
you no respect
what is that Rodney Dangerfield oh yeah
Rodney Dangerfield I don't see I don't
drink before I go onstage and I say
Rodney King is the victus one of the
victims yeah wait a 6 degree of
separation Rodney King from himself wait
Harry basil Rodney Dangerfield oh you're
talking about Rodney okay I get no
respect I'm sure he said that at some
point during the beating hey I got no
respect yeah do you think we'll ever get
to that kind of a racial stuff again I
don't think that we will yeah I feel
like we're I feel like we're going up on
a race war right now you do the way
things are going shaking down like I
followed the maybe the wrong people on
Instagram but like it seems like like
I'll tell you I'll tell you the race war
that is happening and if you don't know
that then you're not paying attention
close enough feminism has a race war
inside it inside of it dude there
there's this I just read an article
yesterday saying the white feminists are
the new Nazis really yeah because white
feminism doesn't I get from what this
article said this isn't me but white
feminism is is does not account for the
struggles of the of the women of color
they only account for their own struggle
Lena Dunham I guess is the perfect
example in this article they said this I
don't I'm not but she went after Odell
Beckham jr. for not flirting with her
and all the black feminists were like oh
I'm sorry because he's a black man he's
got to flirt with you he can't be there
to work you just look at him as a piece
of meat and and
and Lena Dunham was like Oh Amy sadly
our friend Amy is in that group that
people do she got so much [ __ ]
trouble for Jesus I really like that
sometimes I wonder is she I think it's a
business person oh I don't think she's a
bad person but I start to wonder once
you get into that level of making money
in that level like how much of you just
becomes a business she's okay she okay
she got in trouble for doing Beyonce's
lemonade video on the set of snatched
she got a lot of trouble they're like
cultural appropriation now I am some of
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] ridiculous
some of that stuff to me is [ __ ]
ridiculous like at a certain point it's
like if we're all supposed to mix it's
like things are gonna get appropriate
like if you want to talk about some of
the things that are like been the latest
like hypothetical slave owners a lot of
it has been people owning the rights of
performers like and across all
ethnicities you know and like I don't
[ __ ] know man so much it makes me mad
brah you know Donna you probably don't
cuz you are [ __ ] unattractive to a lot
of men when you're Odell Beckham jr. can
tell me a lot of decent looking women
everything yeah he's got his he gets she
gets any DeVito looks [ __ ] better
than Lena Dunham I think or they're
pretty much the same
I would [ __ ] I would probably [ __ ] him
first cuz he had curlier hair you know
she just seems like a blank like I wanna
I do wanna have sex with a woman because
they have a vagina but I don't want just
really that's a good reason but I don't
want that person to be just a complete
[ __ ] and that's what Lena Dunham seems
like to me actually we couldn't even
find the vagina because she's just a
[ __ ] I think she's just a business
person and she doesn't care really about
whim and all that family to the hurried
but at a certain point when things
become a business I don't think it can
just be about what your cause is anymore
well that's what I worry about have is
on us I'll defend Amy in this statement
but she gets so big that I think there
she has a responsibility to say certain
things for young ladies who look up to
her right she can't just [ __ ] be like
we are right now in the [ __ ] [ __ ] I
agree and so I think she you know but
also celebrities get to this point and I
think that that's the thing
a lot of celebrities unattractive these
days is because that there are they're
not real anymore but there's there's no
nuance to it it's like you say something
in an order of you set is taken into
context and you're like no no note or
taken out of context you're like no take
it in context I was [ __ ] around we're
two comics were bullshitting yeah like
this isn't like like I didn't mean it
you know but I guess people just want
that sound bite and they want a
clickbait [ __ ] but I think that most of
America thinks that that it doesn't rely
on that anymore I think that's why you
even see like with the election a lot of
people are like I don't think that half
of America is racist [ __ ] that want
to build a wall at all no I think most
people are like I don't and I'll put in
at least I know this guy's a [ __ ] I know
who Donald Trump is yeah he's a [ __ ]
Moulin crook probably yeah just like
every other [ __ ] old white guy in my
town on so I'll put him in all of them
piece of [ __ ] sorry I don't mean to get
heated bro no I agree with you man I
think if you look and you go like like
when Chris Hardwick got in trouble and
they're like it's it's gone viral he
would they need to fire him I looked
online it was 5,000 people tweeting
about it 5,000 people yeah 5,000 people
that was although job is to tweet about
[ __ ] all day and not to do anything
anything and do you think my dad knew
about it no no do you think any of his
friends knew about it and hope do you
know who what really [ __ ] blew my
mind is I was in I was when I was there
when I found out I was in Birmingham
Alabama doing the stardome and I was
doing news and I like getting ready to
do news and I said I was I was getting
miked up and and one of the guys just a
guy working for like the janitorial
places I said oh [ __ ]
Chris Hardwick and he goes I love that
guy and I go I was like you're a fan of
Chris Hardwick he was doing I love
walking dead I was like well he's in
trouble he goes I hope you don't get
fired I love his show talking dead and I
was like well you know what happened he
goes I don't give a [ __ ] what happened
on this like it show yeah that's the
majority America is like man I'm not
gonna read it like now look for the
Harvey Weinstein's yeah it's time for
them to lose your job but the nuance of
like the things with Hardwick you're
like no it's not going viral the whole
world doesn't know about it it's like
bill burr you say I remember he got in
trouble one time I said how's that going
and he goes he was what he's talking
about I said oh you know the thing
everyone's talking about who's talking
about a part who's
talking about it who and I said I don't
know and he goes exactly nobody and I
was like yeah and he goes no one is it's
it's 400 people losing their [ __ ]
minds
yeah and that's what it is these days
that's what it is until it comes after
you one day and you're like it's
everybody right now yeah I'm sure the he
gets nervous I remember like I remember
one point at one time I had gone on a
couple dates with uh one of the Real
Housewives ladies right really and
suddenly I'm at the gym and I'm just
running on the treadmill it's like a
regular day and it's unlike the E news
ticker you know through and it was like
and then there are pitch and I was just
like this is and I felt like I never
want to be I don't want that to be part
of my life at all because it was this
other creature like my phone started
going Kratt like it was it was on it was
just like make it stop it was like make
it stop this isn't it was out of context
it was just it was everything but it was
just like make it stop this isn't even a
real thing it was just this this
uncomfortable thing and it felt like you
weren't even a person then there was
just tons of judgment or just not even
judgment he she was a pretty lady and
and she was a you know and and I think
she's very charming and stuff like that
but a lot of stuff was happening outside
of you that you had met that had nothing
no control over and nothing to do with
that had nothing to do with who you were
as a person and it felt wrong that's
what it felt like if I like man
whatever's going on right here is is not
right not just to me but as a scope of
the way to do things you know yeah that
was way scary man that was a scary scary
moment I remember you know talking to my
manager Mike can you just make this stop
like this just you know and a couple
days later it went away yeah that's the
thing is I think you know if you it's re
always says just bury her head in the
sand for a week get off line go do
something really cool go camping
battlin goes away I think I mean I don't
know I've never I mean I've had that
I've had it happen to me a couple times
with like friends like we're like we're
like you say something shitty on a
podcast and it kind of blows up and
you're like ah [ __ ] and if you just kind
of like sit back it goes away you're
like if you're like me you make coffee
at home you know because look now you
got to walk somewhere and get coffee no
way sir
coffee at home that's why I do it you
don't think I can be a barista dude I
can all I have to do is be angry so I
make coffee at home and the coffee that
I make right now is bixby coffee bi xby
coffee okay and Bix we got that tasty
cut you know a lot of people don't even
know what you they don't even know where
their coffee beans are from you look at
their beans I like oh these beans even
have parents you know but bixby coffee
man
it feels just like it has been raised
well and right when you order it that's
right when they roast it so those beans
are made fresh to order bixby coffee
they make Keurig pods if you go like
that
they make Nespresso pods and this [ __ ]
is just so much better than most other
coffees because a lot of the stuff out
there is literally trash Bixby is
delivered right to your door and just
for you guys enter the promo code Theo
at checkout and your first two weeks of
coffee is just five dollars that's right
two weeks of coffee for $5 Bixby coffee
com use promo code Theo and get that
good [ __ ] I wanted to bounce out of LA
one of the balance when I was on travel
to I want to bounce out of LA and go out
to like Boulder and thank God I didn't
like I fired from Travel Channel well
moving at you though
no you couldn't go get a house I'm out
there and live there if you wanted to or
do you and honestly do you think is I
think about this too like I think about
you know if I weren't able to catch some
breaks and get to a place where I could
have you know enough of where I could
you know still have my fans come see me
without the fear of losing the ability
to have create fans if you can do if you
could do I mean theoretically if you
could do this in a big market say like
Chicago where you have big comics coming
in and they knew your podcast was still
relevant like Joe could do his podcast
anywhere right people are flying out for
Joe's podcast so yeah if you get your
podcast that big I could just do
stand-up on my podcast make social media
interesting I don't think I need
television I ma'am I've been offered
I've been on Grey's I've been on for
television pretty aggressively lately
and I just passed on it I'm like I don't
I don't want to do it I want to make my
thing now he didn't do it with all
things comedy making my cooking
oh yeah podcasts come out you know once
a quarter do some bang out some podcasts
do some sets go back out live a full
life
I would love to my wife just my wife
won't do it our kids are already dialed
in like we're in high school my two
oldest is in high school my youngest is
getting ready to go into high school in
two years all our friends are out here
my managers agents I mean I guess
ultimately I'm just in the [ __ ] game
I mean I'm locked in yeah you know and
it's so say air he had it up in prison
let's go yeah dude you're like [ __ ]
post and I'm you're like Nabisco Malone
I wouldn't want and that was a post
Nabisco joke a lot of people won't get
that it was good thanks man I wouldn't
mind doing a residency in Vegas damn
little Ralphie that's what they would
call it oh my god what you did was just
like Ralphie May that was the name of it
oh man you looked just like wrapped like
you were that lazy dude I feel guilty
now I know that I had nothing to do with
this but me and him were on a cruise
ship right before he passed like a few
months for a pouch does he sleep in the
middle of a shake he has sleep in the
middle of a cruise ship six hundred
pounds or five hundred pounds you
couldn't sleep on a side of the cruise
ship could you he was sleeping a lot
that trip he wasn't getting up and doing
much huh and and I went we went to his
room once a day and when we go in there
and smoke a joint in his room and and
what he's just laying in bed the whole
time he was laying in bed a lot he'd get
up and move around I mean I mean I'm I'm
not I'm definitely not speaking ill of
the dead but anyone was on that ship
would agree he'd move around like
probably two out of the seven days we
were there he'd get up and do stuff and
he not often not often was he moving
around and when you say like like
because I've never been around anybody
that has had that much of a you know an
impairment that wasn't like you know I
had a friend that didn't have any legs
and he didn't do that much and then I
had another lady that I think was just
lazy when I was growing up you know and
she also was taking care of a kid a
black child you know and both her and
her husband were white and they were
like it was their child everybody even
though the lady that swept at his school
bus was black miss tilly real and it was
obviously her child and we'd go over
there and it was the weirdest thing he'd
like this our son boogie and it would be
like dude they had him dressed up like a
little cowboy and [ __ ] like to make him
just see me wider dude I know joke I
revert this little boogie heat up on
these red boots and he would do this
little [ __ ] dance by the door when
you went in and it was like what like
even I know that you can't get a black
kid out of two white people no matter
how hard you try I love that name boogie
do you know there's a I met a football
player in a place called the chatterbox
one time booger mcFarland booger
mcFarland that's all the time at the
airport day now I wanted to talk about
so miss Borland they were like these are
my friend booger you know he got the
nickname no cuz he would hit people so
hard that they'd have to [ __ ] pick
him out of their nose are you serious
I did not not those places always have
boogers the only other booger I met was
Revenge of the Nerds
yes hair pie and now you imagine no but
I hit you so hard you have to pick me
out of your [ __ ] McKim introduced me
to him at the Chatterbox in Tampa when I
was high as [ __ ] and she's like hey this
is my friend I was like hey man how you
doing he's a big guy played at LSU yeah
and he was like and she's like hey how
you doing I'm Bert he goes I'm booger
and I went I could not stop [ __ ]
laughing and I and no one else was
laughing because he was a buck at the
time yeah everyone knew booger man
follow ya booger so let's go on so I
want to hear more about that Rafi mo
this this thing yeah so I don't know
what I'm saying gonna be in Vegas so we
were all hanging out oh yeah you guys
were on the cruise ship and I said that
I hadn't heard many people that couldn't
move around that much
he hardly enough he is the reason I
called this special secret time the
Netflix special because he we were all
hanging out and he was like I got off
for the residency in Vegas I was like
man I was like roughly I think that's
the best thing for you in my opinion
you go you get in Vegas you get healthy
you don't have to fly you don't have to
travel
I guess traveling was the thing keeping
him healthy because he was moving around
they had to get him right up and out but
he didn't think of that huh you have to
get up and go to the to the bus you have
to get up at the gas station maybe go
get a drink you know do stuff you have
to get up and pay for gas you have
together
there's things he had to do I guess but
I was like go to Vegas dude because in
my head I go go to Vegas get healthy get
it get involved some UFC gym out there
yeah where they're like you know maybe
it's not I don't even know but like
they're fans of Rogen's pockets they
know who I am and the let me work out or
like some guy keeps an eye on me and
it's like make sure I'm doing something
healthy yeah and then go in like go play
golf once a day do a show don't drink
cuz you can just come home yeah I'll be
great for me and I told him I was like
dude do it and so then we did one show I
got to be dead honest - probably the
funniest I've ever seen him in my entire
life he had a joke about have a mediocre
dick you ever heard this and he goes out
he goes wow you got they're talking
about having big dick I got mediocre
dick
no one wants big dick ladies you don't
want big dick leaving your [ __ ] like a
horse reaching for a sugar tube like he
did nine of those do nine of those and
I'm [ __ ] dying laughing you don't
want big because at nine different tack
he was so good at that
of doing those nine different tags and
then I went up after him and I was
buzzed already I was already drunk and
and I never get but it was like a cruise
ship I'm cow head screws Calton screws I
got high with my ax
yeah he's a sweetheart I got hired with
Ralphie and the things I found funny
were just secrets that I was gonna say
on stage and then Ralph - Ralph Ian cow
head so they could just and just be like
secrets and like I was and I just first
joke was like secret time I got a shower
dry my [ __ ] in the bed and Ralphie
lost it and he's like he does do that
[ __ ] don't you and I was like yeah and
he goes more secrets player and so I
just kept telling secrets like secret
times name is special Cu times name is
special and I got on stage and Ralph
he's like that's the funniest [ __ ] I've
ever you say he goes just tell secrets
just tell seek oh you kept going tell
what's so true it's like you you like
yeah there's Sonny you like telling
secrets I love telling secrets like when
I go like the perfect example is like
when I go see
I had sex with six people and then I go
[ __ ] it's like it's women right like
it's you just um and I also feel like if
you keeps like and that's the other part
is I talk [ __ ] about my family so I
don't want them seeing it
sorry that's other part of the secret
time but it Ralphie was like he all
night we went to dinner that night at
the Italian restaurant on the boat and
he was like he kept going
tell me more secrets Bert tell me more
secrets and I just was like and when
you're open up yeah and you and you're
like I was telling them everything I got
the clap in college though I yeah and
then I just tell them the story and they
were laughing and I was like oh yeah I
guess that's kind of what I do on stage
is just tell a secret and then my kid
dumb as [ __ ] and I tell the story yeah
so yeah so that but Ralphie had to do
with me
daddy that's crazy what is it about it
you think cuz now it's like what do you
think it is about secrets that you like
telling them or like telling things you
shouldn't tell because some people tell
jokes some people tell stories young
people but yeah there is something about
you that it's like um amber says things
you come baby she shouldn't say even you
said it when you came in you kind of
have to like sometimes like you know
some people are okay with that because
you're joking around at your boys and
some people aren't yeah I don't know I
think I think I'm super I think in real
life I'm really insecure and I'm really
I have a low self-esteem and I think I I
always thought like when I was a kid I
thought jacking off that you were gay
like I didn't know that that meant that
you just were a regular person right and
so I lived with that until I was like
until I was 18 years old you were
jerking off thinking you were gay then I
thought I just thought I must be gay I
can't stop I must be one of those weird
gay guys that's only attracted to women
because I don't
I'm only jacking off the chicks and I'm
loading up with chicks I had sex with a
chick but I can't quit jacking off and
then we got no our fraternity and they
said something about jacking off and I
was like hold on you guys you guys do
that and they're like everyone does it I
was like where the [ __ ] was this open
and honesty like where was this my whole
entire [ __ ] life and they call it
jacking off with it yeah [ __ ] like a
name Jack no that's when they started
calling it rub them one out everyone
rubs one out yeah and I was like rubs
one out like yeah you know and I was
like dude Eddie Bravo said they people
would just it used to say play with
themselves you know and it was totally
normal what you gonna what's going on
today man I'm probably gonna just you
know have you know have some kool-aid
maybe
play with myself or maybe you know get a
new harp or something dude I wish that
that had happened earlier from me
growing up because it was I really was
like I must be a pervert yeah there must
be something wrong with me like I don't
think I ever really liked it at a
certain age you go I'm definitely
straight I'm I'm sleeping with I had
lost my virginity to a chick all I want
are chicks I'm the first time I felt a
chick up in the bushes remember when you
go back into the bushes yeah and just
make out just hold just play with your
tit a million different ways you're like
I've been waiting for this day my entire
[ __ ] life oh my god oh my god oh my
god like oh dude I remember some girl
didn't want uh me to she was like so
nervous about my god I guess seeing us
touch each other or whatever we're in a
sand trap on a golf course right yeah oh
[ __ ]
she was nervous she took her [ __ ]
pants off and everything and then like
tried to cover as much of her body as
she could with [ __ ] sand right so
then I don't even I'm still I'm young
dude I can get through some sand for
some crotch you know like this is you
know yeah this is [ __ ] you know I'm
fired up you know I'm saying I could
probably shoot semen through a [ __ ]
wall of sand at that time let's go
vagina as a golfer would say she was a
fried egg so then I'm playing with this
you know touching this girl's crotch
with sand everywhere and it was you know
it ended up kind of stopping the
scenario and Shia and and and she didn't
you know she got I want to say sick but
she had to you know talk to the mom and
stuff a bunch after that I got a sandy
hand job one time and Clearwater Beach
did you Oh every hand out of a saying on
there dude you can't keep saying off
your dick South uh north of desk just
rubbing the skin off and you just feel
like just it'll be over in a second
we're just gonna get through this is the
hard part this is love this is mile 20
of the marathon come on dude yeah [ __ ]
yeah god I miss those days like when
like you're when like you were like you
get so excited to touch body and you'd
be like oh my god oh yeah I come over
the first time I finger to chick I was
allow secret time I was thought I was in
the haunted house ride at Disney World
in Orlando and it was the part we're
like and I just I never thought about it
I never like I was in eighth grade knows
like we're making out
on the ride and I'm playing with her
boob hmm and then all of a sudden I just
was like let's see if this works and it
just went in so quick and like you just
it just worked it just went yeah and I
was like whoa and then I didn't know
what to do with my finger and I just
left it there like I was taking her
temperature yeah left it in there like
yeah pretty nice
that's swaggy day she's like huh I'm
like that's an old doctor move dude dude
bro
I remember one time I was in I was doing
a college show somewhere this is like 10
years ago and afterwards I was drinking
at a house when I was drinking at a
house right yeah I didn't know the house
was on campus but the police show up and
they say this house is technically on
campus it didn't look anything on campus
at all is like a regular house yeah look
like a dormitory or like a you know I'm
a quadruplex or anything like that so
the cops came took me to jail right and
there was this girl I was flirting with
and I was like exciting maybe I get some
you know hookup
anyway I get back to the hotel or my
buddies are staying in the morning the
girls slept over she hooked up with my
buddy right yeah and and he had broken
both of us he had two broken arms though
so my other buddy had to hold him up
while he was [ __ ] her like he like he
like laid on got on top of her but then
my other buddy was real strong like
Adonis like leaned over and just held
him up the whole time by his chest so he
could just like dangle his arms like
because my buddy was on top like he
could just dangle his arms and still
live sex and then me and the girl ended
up having sex dude and she had the
darkest bush I've ever seen in my life
and it was like three or four inches
long it was straight she was like black
she was african-american but just kind
of in the [ __ ] just and it was just the
hair was just very you know it was more
of African and type of hair you know and
it was just so exciting it was such an
exciting time and that was up in
Binghamton I think I remember I remember
in my junior year high school mm-hmm
yeah no moon oh it must've been
sophomore year of high school we're at
Tai Rodriguez's house and and everyone's
everyone's hooking up yeah just a bunch
of girls bunch of guys it's just like
you know just like [ __ ] like I think
that what do they call like
just makeout fest or something and then
the next morning we're all eatin
breakfast and everyone's like did you
hook up I was like yeah I can I made out
pretty [ __ ] aggressively with I'm
just saying name like Jennifer and
they're like they're like really and my
buddy Sean Tucker goes what time and I
go how an [ __ ] probably like
nighttime one and he goes you think it
was one more round two I said why don't
I was right before we all went to bed
and they started laughing I go why he
goes because she was sucked my dick at
midnight I was like oh and that's when
everyone's like so wait what's hookers
Dictate I shouldn't say his name I guess
my bucket
what's lookers details yeah he knows
yeah those [ __ ] times you're like oh
god this is gonna make me into a
comedian I guess I gotta have a sense of
humor about this [ __ ] I've never been a
cool dude with chicks I wish really
never never I could never turn it off
but deke oh I could see that I was
always trying to be funny
you've only got back to the room I could
I just couldn't turn it off really yeah
I got uncomfortable and then like
leaning in the fur first guess oh dude
that's like it's almost like talking a
different language for me like to be
able to like go from what this is right
here like this energy right here which
will work this works with a chick like
hanging out making her laugh get back to
the room and then going from this to
yeah slow do you remember how whenever
you were you long oh yeah yeah that's
okay it's like cool kissing a [ __ ]
lizard and I kiss with my eyes open
oh really yeah that's insane you scared
the [ __ ] out of some chicks before and
then they open their eyes like what the
[ __ ] did you like what what'd I do that
heat robber
Oh everyone played spin the bottle at
this party and like the prettiest girl
in our town dude this girl had the big I
was in love with this girl her name was
Emily Baumgartner and she was gonna kiss
me and I could just I got this weird
feeling at first I thought that she had
to vomit and I had to vomit at the same
time I didn't know what the feeling was
right but later on in life I realize
that means we kind of were into each
other it isn't weird like a yeah and
then you're like
I'm getting sick like oh my god feel
that's [ __ ] brilliant
the oh my god that's so [ __ ]
brilliant they she goes in to kiss you
but it does look like you're about to be
sick like she's like and then you look
oh I think I'm gonna throw up now
I do wanna get a bucket oh my god and
then we just put each other's mouths in
the [ __ ] force of Clyde but no I but
for me it was there was something going
on between us and she liked me yeah and
I thought whenever like we looked at
each other we there was this weird
feeling and that's when I thought we're
both gonna vomit like I was like Oh
something does she have to vomit maybe I
some you know it was just uncomfortable
but then it was time to kiss like the
bottle spun or whatever and then I was
like holy [ __ ] I [ __ ] kiss like the
girl in my dreams and I didn't know how
to kiss anybody dude and as I got closer
to her my mouth kept opening wider and
wider because I've seen something on
television right yeah and then I
literally just wrapped my whole [ __ ]
mouth like around her kind of mouth and
chin and somebody laughed dude some
little [ __ ] imp some little [ __ ]
Moulin Bluebird what would you rather
have you ready yeah what would you
rather have I'd rather that she had an
Instagram so that I could see her once
in a while cuz she doesn't she doesn't
there's no pictures she could be
deceased and if she is I'm really sorry
to her family but I've never seen any
pictures of her online I looked
everywhere I looked for the black kid in
my neighborhood last night did you yeah
I looked for him I think I found him
he's front we have two mutual friends
bye and I think that and then he's lives
in Tampa if I was looking for him last
night I just woke up had a dream about
him and his sister and and I and I
looked him up and I think I got him I
his dad's on there but his mom's not on
there so I'm like his mom might have
passed but uh what would you rather have
no question for me to go back in time
and re-experience your first kiss hmm go
back in time and it reappear e'en Stu
first time you had sex with someone
first kiss yeah [ __ ] first sex first
kiss Murray Koval 7th grade we were up
in my bedroom our parents were
downstairs having like a dinner party no
we were just messing around and I was on
my back his she was on her back Luther
listen to music she just rolled over
rolled over I think we were head to head
just rolled over leaned over started to
kiss him upside down and I just do my
tits got loose and shaky and I lost my
stomach and then I was like huh and then
I heard my sister bird mom and dad want
um ready to come downstairs and I'm like
oh dude I and by the way I kissed her
probably like four times and every
single time felt like a first kiss yeah
dude I remember there was this girl
named Chrissy hunt when I was real young
and she could have been seven or she
could have been [ __ ] 40 and she the
first time I guess I think she had the
blood in her mouth for some reason and
it was because her teeth were all banged
up I don't know what happened she may
have been in a wreck right before we
kissed and uh but she had blood in her
mouth and I remember thinking it that
was crazy and then years later but I
remember oh the kids a neighborhood kids
would lock us in a room together we
weren't allowed to come out until we
kissed and it was just the hardest
[ __ ] thing in the world bro it was
like I was just cuz I knew we both knew
we had to and I had to do something I
was supposed to like be the man you know
but I couldn't be the man
yeah and I'm in the room and all I want
to do is kiss her dude not usually been
humping my pillow at night and my buddy
would come over and we would practice
I'm gonna pose one side of a whistle and
blow it on the other one if he was doing
like bad moves on the pillow yeah way to
I kind of Raby back off there you go
corners neutral corners of the bed Oh
bleep there you go up under up under Oh
feathers feathers but it was Farnborough
and
I remember in junior high school finally
I got to Daddy groans she look just like
a boy everybody thought that she was a
boy and we would kiss I get there the
school bus would company would come from
the older school while the older kids
were and me and her would be standing
there like waiting to kiss every time we
would always just end up hugging and
then somebody yelled out one time just
kiss each other you [ __ ] and use the
n-word I stayed right and we were both
white and we're like [ __ ] we got to do
it now you know what I'm saying like
people are getting us racially confused
they're starting to hate us so much
[Laughter]
so dude it's just crazy the power of
racism dude just overwhelming whatever
for four years like a year and she
always wanted like base out clothes and
stuff for like all like dances and all
like dances she was too early he's fall
[ __ ] oh how are you with Tara lesbians
like I went through a tear of them I
could see that I had a period where I
was I would date a girl and then
immediately they come out gay and I blah
god damn it
is it me it's not me I think there I was
just like the first step there was the I
was the least threatening of what they
were looking for you're like Jon Lovitz
in a league of their own just every time
he goes they just pull the lesbian out
of do not some interesting conversations
man it's interesting to think right now
in my hands I have something and it's
the world's thinnest phone case some
people say oh I got the thinnest phone
case well this place definitely has it
it is absolutely as thin as possible
it's a very sleek and luxurious it's
more level like a condom for your phone
you know like your phone's going to do
something naughty and it wants to kind
of protect itself from viruses you know
then you can have this the minimal case
it is 0.01 inches thick it is it's so
lean and slender it's like if your phone
wants to wear something sultry for a
night out on the town it's not an
off-road type of case now it's not gonna
really you know it's not that you know
that that off-road or style if your
phone wants to be in a truck or do
something devious
wild wild but if your friend wants to be
sexy it is the world's thinnest case and
you can get it the minimal case go to M
in ml case calm for 15% off use the code
Theo
that's M in ml case CAS EECOM for 15%
off use the code Theo I think that the
guy Alex Jones like talking about you
know kids families that those shootings
not being real and stuff like that it's
just too much yeah I don't you know I
never really found out Jones enough to
know what he was doing I only saw him he
was on Rogan and he got drunk and it was
just it was a funny interview yeah um
but I like there were people that really
despised him I think it's wrong to shut
I do think it's wrong to shut a guy down
like that I do I don't think it's wrong
I think that I think that the fact that
and I by the way I don't know why Alex
Jones got shut down I know he said that
the the shooting was a hoax I'm a little
shocked that anyone ever took him
seriously in the right place like I
can't believe that I part of me goes
we're all know he's like not it's a joke
thing like you really think that right
and maybe he does I don't know but I
definitely don't take him serious like
that's the thing I wonder if at a
certain point when you don't
does he really do you really believe
that or are you just pushing something
to get up trying to view your views it's
right and so that's when it starts to
make me scale like that's when I'm like
what it what is going on here like cuz
that's not a safe thing for me I don't
think that's not a for me it doesn't
seem like a neat thing to push that's a
sad thing like it's not a real thing is
that really helping somebody like some
of these considered conspiracy theorists
at a certain point it's just like yeah
we're probably outside of some
information but part of you is making
everything a conspiracy because you
don't want to you don't feel accepted or
something you know it's like it just
starts me make me wondering like the
psychology behind it you know some
except I had I had an uber driver
yesterday who gave me the most brilliant
conspiracies here I've never heard he
goes he goes man I know Waze is getting
[ __ ] paid off I said what do you mean
he goes I think it's taking us the long
way
so we'll go by these businesses yeah I
don't do that and then I started
thinking yeah why would
businesses pay ways and go hey man if
you got people driving through LA have
them come down Laurel Canyon that's
where all the businesses are don't take
them back roads just have them it's
faster and like hey here's next a little
extra and and ways does have contacts
with some of the people yeah like with
something like you could be driving it
all sudden like do you like fried
chicken and you're like I do and they're
like churches is on Laurel Canyon in
Magnolia and you're like oh [ __ ] I want
fried chicken like it's almost like
those pop-up ads that come up on
Facebook yeah but I too much conspiracy
theory I brought your dad used to eat
subway for you before you passed away
yeah I can't get too close to those cuz
here's me Xperia see there's I just
don't believe in them like I just I just
go nah I'm not that I'm not that person
right so the alex jones thing kind of
threw me off i was like let him talk but
he's been talking for [ __ ] years i've
never listened yeah I think anyone
really I mean no offense to anyone is a
big out Jones supporter like I've heard
him on Rogen stuff I've seen Joey on his
podcast and I would probably do his
podcast or be interested I do it a harpy
but I'm never sitting and taking him
seriously ever and the fact that people
are like no we need to shut Boyce's like
this down I'm like that's crazy to me
I'm like they shut down all the prank
videos on YouTube because those are fake
instigating racism like shut down all
the breastfeeding videos on YouTube well
shut down a half aha I mean half a
Hollywood's full of [ __ ] it's like dude
you have like I can I go back to this
all the time but it's like you know they
push so much diversity in this app but
don't you remember like what three years
ago when black people were bagging they
get a glow a Golden Globe nomination or
what was an Academy Award they well yeah
I'm gonna feel weird boycotting the
[ __ ] Academy Awards and they're like
hashtag something or other yeah and then
they were like and it's Jen look I'm off
I'm all for diversity I don't give a
[ __ ] you know I'm dying to go see crazy
rich Asians yeah but I'm not going to
see it to support diversity I'm just
going to see cuz it looks like a good
movie right I think that's where we'll
know we're all equal like dude trust me
to say this I did not go to see Black
Panther to simply to to support black
people right I want to see Black Panther
Chris is a badass [ __ ] a movie yeah my
kids want to see it I wanted to see it
yeah and so like I think whatever that
does to [ __ ] make more [ __ ] happen
I'm cool with like whatever you have to
do to activist
to make [ __ ] happen I'm very cool with
like just I'm letting you know that
there's a lot of regular people out
there yeah a lot of regular D [ __ ] I
watch Katt Williams special yeah oh I
love can twins I don't watch I didn't do
it to support I didn't like I don't
cognizant ly go like well I gotta make
sure to watch a little rels yeah and I
never want to be that person like who is
that person that's not even a person
like if you're doing something like I'll
do good [ __ ] like I'll watch good [ __ ]
and I think that that's what hopefully
we start to get back to is like let's
just let's [ __ ] be funny
and yeah and especially like from you
know I I get it's [ __ ] up that it's
like the only people like Holly was kind
of cornered themselves were the only
people they can make fun of her like
poor white people you know yeah and dude
I don't I don't tune into that makes me
mad too what's the what's I don't even
know it's to calm that why people are in
a Big Bang Theory yeah I don't - I don't
watch it I don't know if someone told me
you should because you're white man I'd
be like oh excuse me who the [ __ ] do you
think you're talking to
yeah I don't you into anything based on
someone's skin color I tune into people
go it's good yeah like everyone say
black-ish is good yeah and I was like
okay let me check it out it's [ __ ]
awesome yeah it's [ __ ] awesome and I
was like dude are the mick I didn't do
that cuz I'm a FEMINIST yeah I did it
cuz the mix funny is [ __ ] on Jones what
about him
I didn't care for him cause he's black
is he black there you go Oh Arnold
Schwarzenegger a little bit anyone ever
tell you that
[Laughter]
that's Nick Davis our producer and Nick
was a premature baby thrill yeah that's
what we've surmised but look how old how
old are you now Nick I'm 30 years old
there you go boy
so anything's possible thirty years old
but never be nine months
yeah we could keep talking forevers is
interesting man I'm talking forever man
you know you know for a fact I hope you
know for a fact there's a handful of
people in this business that have been a
fan ear since day one and yeah that guy
yeah I'm in that small group of people
like there are a lot of people I think
there's a lot of people finding you
right now a lot of people are like going
like oh [ __ ] he's my new favorite comic
I've been there I've been there
I remember in reality by his back you
you
had me laughing consistently more than
any one person on that show you and
Donnell Rollins were my two favorite you
Thank You Manuel I mean you always been
very nice and you know you've always
said you've always said nice thing you
always made me laugh you were certainly
walking mean that was a really fun show
you know I couldn't have any better
introduction just being around comedians
I mean like just Don out there was so
much funny [ __ ] on there Donna Rollins
the very first day Kyle sees comes up
Kyle sees has made 12 different hats for
all 12 episodes
yeah and Kyle sees as a comedian who is
he was doing well at the time who's
doing really well he now a major and he
he made hats that said week 1 week 2
week 3 week 4 week 5 and he walked up to
Donna Rollins it was it was red grant
Donna Rollins Chris Fairbanks me and
Kyle Kyle cease and he walks up on the
steps of that house in Encino and he
goes hey fellas and Donnell just shakes
his head and he goes man you're right
you are the weak one Dan and he goes
what he goes your hat it says weak one
you are the weak one and Kyle goes huh
and and Donnell goes I hope you got a
hat it just says weak because you're
weak son and Kyle's like I think week
would be spelled differently Donnell he
goes not in my neighborhood
yeah and Donnell came from a
neighborhood then he use all the vowels
but yeah I remember that she was wild
out of the gate and then it was out of
them too to go home yeah oh dude you
made the judge the first episode they
had you picked to send home yeah and I
remember Chris Fairbanks walked up to me
and he goes I can't go home she were
making I always say this it's a high
number it was like five hundred dollars
in episode yes which was huge money then
this was 10 years ago 12 years ago and
the more you were on the show the more
money you got like if you got kicked off
on week one you didn't get pay for all
the episodes right so you wanted to stay
on so it actually got competitive yeah
cuz people wanted to make the money and
so um and so Chris Fairbanks it was he
thought he was gonna get sent home the
very first day and he was sitting in
line with me and he goes he goes you
know feel and I said yeah then he goes
what should I say something I don't want
to get sent home I go I don't know maybe
just go up to him and say you don't want
to get sent home he was like really I
was like sure and Chris Fairbanks what
opportunity was hey will you not send me
home and you were like uncle
okay I state the like for three or four
episodes life stayed longer than I did
yeah and then and then you were like and
then you were like Donnell Kelsey's the
thing is we had all had our moms there
yeah Kyle's my I think McConnell's mom
might have passed away
yeah cause mom passed away or somewhere
mr. fly or mister and let's hike wait to
be the same thing either
there it goes that's it and so how the
[ __ ] do you say your last name von Kahr
natal ski that's really your last name
yeah and we got ridden get rid of it but
well first of all it means the Jews
Slayer so I can't even use it in Los
Angeles are you shitty people thought I
was Mexican growing up in Louisiana
Devlin pole is right it pulls I'm
literally frog when my father's
Nicaragua but this is this is nowhere on
on the Internet either you can't buy it
on Amazon not iTunes it bought it
anywhere I have it at home which is
crazy yeah I've got it on a computer
somewhere
sure you do nobody believes had and just
real quick real quick a computer one of
my computer's Oh Jeff Garcia was on a
road he left very first episode was too
good for the show he told us that and
he's still too good for everything he
told us that huh yeah yeah the
quarterback Jeff Carson it was let me
show ya two extra weeks in you if you
would guys I'm not even a comedian
before your quarterback dude two weeks
less than two weeks in two weeks more in
the womb and he what if I could add that
here but I got that question right oh
but what I'm saying is Jeff Garcia the
quarterback spilled wine on my shirt one
time the only the first time I'd ever
been in a San Francisco at a bar and uh
and he paid me for it but yeah Kyle's
he's went home first Jeff Garcia said to
us no offense I'm bigger than you guys
yeah and I'm this is below me I'm out
and all of us were like so weak does he
count for the first one no no he left I
was like no no he's making the first
line and all of us want to be like Jeff
can you get voted out first yeah so that
we can all make another 75 everybody do
this warden
not above you yeah by the way like look
wait cuz he didn't want his mom to come
cuz II don't want his mom to be
embarrassed actually remember that oh is
that is that part of it I don't know man
that was uncomfortable they brought our
moms there and they made us
they made us first of all seduce our
moms mmm
but you didn't have a mom yeah do did
you know that your mom there well your
dad it passed away that it passed away
but Kyle didn't have a mom and so they
brought in this hot and sour porn star
dude who I may be just a stripper maybe
just a model but yeah we we were young
too if you even got a stepmom she was a
porn star yeah my dad's marrying a poor
oh really that lady that works at the
bank you're like oh yeah you're right
dude look at this list of people for two
seconds people that I'm not saying I'm
not calling out Jeff Garcia but people
at the time he thought he was bigger
than donnell rawlings tours everywhere
with Dave Chappelle yeah
today I know walls might be the funniest
on here too Tiffany Haddish one of the
biggest movie stars in the world right
now yeah Amy Schumer
one of the biggest movie stars in the
world right now
red Grant tours everywhere with Katt
Williams
and by the way legit sellout act himself
he does those big tours with like steps
many some on like yes spicy and they all
go and they sell out theaters and then
Maria Turner for Chrysler Theo von both
Rockets bought at the same time and mo
mandel so Lee showed uh truTV yeah and
just told us sort of written series to
Amazon just recently and he and I have a
pilot together a Comedy Central Chris
Fairbanks a voiceover for a beer company
in the northwest yep and just recently
got a hip replacement yeah dude that was
he he was over in my house and he was
like before it and he was doing my
podcast like this mm-hm
he's like yeah it's really rough it's
really rough and now he's like
skateboarding again yeah
which is very danger is one of the top
motivational speakers in the world
that's true that's very true actually
it's crazy man yeah and Jeff Garcia is
not even in the league anymore he's not
he was in the league he'd retired
football oh and you retired he retired
from comedy Jeff hey Jeff Jeff actually
had a I was really he really was the
biggest of all of us at that time though
oh yeah definitely he was he
you didn't know yes that's what he was
he's a noise for Jimmy Neutron and he
was like I don't know hey I remember I
was before you realized that because we
I mean we all got naked a few times
member me who read grant got naked with
luenell on that tub yeah and luenell
still has the same yeah she had that
crazy body type is that one one body
part
I gotta have a naked in that tub with
luenell I took my dick out in that tub
of Nutella luenell and then I saw her
and mom she hated my guts and read and
die now we're like reading on our like
you know that's just how black women
talk Burt you gotta understand she's
just walking to you he's like I hate
your guts whitey yeah she was like why
are you so loud Bert yeah why you black
oh no no and I would be like you're just
as loud as I am no when you talk no one
want to listen I was like a lot of like
okay that's actually a really great
luenell impression I'm doing right now
that's a really that's a [ __ ]
accurate luenell impression she was in
Borodino she's the little blond-haired
girl everybody calls her thick Cisco she
likes Cisco the rapper but there and she
um is in a lot of stuff can you bring
her picture up do you mind
and then she Iran in heard the mantra me
and Steve Byrne were in montreal
montreal and i saw her at the bar
drinking before show i walked up on yo
luenell she went yep
she goes i was good to see you too good
let's get a drink and we just sat and
drank and I was like I thought you hated
me I love you
we're the same person yes that is really
good no you know what she's a special
lady man she always uh she she'll let
you make fun of her she's really cool
and she's always like she's really cool
she's a sweet she is a sweet lady she's
crazy kill didn't Borat - dude she's
killed it in a lot of she's been a lot
of [ __ ] and her stand-ups [ __ ] legit
she sells out everywhere I think she
does sell out everywhere all right let's
take a couple questions that came in
yeah great where you get duper Moretz I
don't see Avenue Avenue special new
special on Netflix called secret I'm
Aaron August 24th after August 24 of the
stream and every day Wow
every day boy all right here's a little
shorty right here move on podcast of
this
we can just say bring here questions for
Bert Kreischer dude you got little
teenagers now brah are you worried about
them boyfriends coming over like
seriously has it happened already no
it's good question that girl's cute
there's one boy that my daughter has a
crush on who is he can't say his name
don't want to blow up or switch his last
name then I can't say that cuz that'll
definitely blow up his spot okay
first name only no what can't but which
is middle name if you had to guess his
middle name is I don't know probably
like one of the Lincoln and so all the
moms are like I think Georgia has got a
crush on him George George George George
alright and I was like really in a first
I got defensive and then I thought I
like this kid like I like it if this is
her first crush if this is her first
kiss this is the right kicks he's a
little nerdy and then and then we were
all at this thing and I said to him I
was like hey we're all going back to my
house to barbecue and all the parents
gonna come back I'm gonna take the kids
back to you want to come over come swim
with us he was like like you could see
it like that uncut he's like yeah and so
I was like come on want you and we all
rode bikes together over
we all went swimming and we got there
naeun have a bathing suit he's like a
zoo Bert and I was like yeah so I went
and got all my bit like a size 40
bathing suits get like tied at nine
times and then with swimming with us and
you could just see him uncomfortable and
I was like okay I'm cool with this kid
he's not the dick who's like you know
what's up I heard your comic you know
Chris D'Elia
yeah dude every kid I meet especially a
[ __ ] is that but here's the funny thing
bro dude that reminded me they had this
dude in our neighborhood not a crush on
his daughter and if you'd like his
daughter this man wanted to see your
dick but not in a way where he's a
pedophile he wanted to make sure you
didn't have a big dick if you were gonna
[ __ ] his daughter how crazy is that
the times have changed man I remember
playing it was an Elvis impersonator for
real yeah so wait how did he want to
look at your dick to him far away like
eight to ten feet away he would just
drop your trunks and [ __ ] shell him I
don't think it was I didn't feel
assaulted I felt like he was honest
about it and he's like I'm out
I spent all my daughter's got a big day
I remember there's a look at this little
thing and he's like your good man I
remember there was a guy but I had to
really put a bunch of cold water on it
first to make it look cool yo make it
look small for him dude I had to
literally hot a piece of ice between my
dick in my [ __ ] nuts to make it even
smaller I do that sometimes there's a
dad in our neighborhood who you'd play
[ __ ] of them and if and if you lost
the letter instead of losing letter yet
to kiss him kiss him lit four small of
his back I don't remember I want to say
on the cheek but maybe sometimes on the
lips that's even get that's key is that
gay or just [ __ ] up I don't know you
definitely did not want to miss shots it
really made competition [ __ ] intense
bro his team shots 70% from three I
remember he'd make a shot never be like
[ __ ] get the chapstick out yeah that's a
great one man that's a great callin
thank you you know cruising beautiful -
yeah pretty girls out there on the
internet anymore yeah
hey what's up guys this is derek rims
from kansas city
so bert still the partier what has been
your lowest of lows when you party other
than the time that you threw up IPAs all
over yourself in the shower all right
thanks guys
this guy knows me yeah well I got a
handful of those I got a handful give us
one uh good one I'll give you three
granny
Doug Stan opes house Oh on the rape
trail which is house light it's a
compound it's like five different houses
other guns out there no no gun I mean I
know none that none out there that I saw
and did you have SWAT or anything like
there's just him and bingo no it's him
bingo chaley it's everyone that's
everyone though it's like and then they
have friends they've people that are in
passing through town and we party like
for three days straight like straight
like I don't think I barely went to bed
and I woke up the day I had to go home
Monday morning but I woke up like Sunday
night
like four in the morning and we're not
leaving until 8:00 and I spent four
hours in that trailer just being like
man you got to clean your [ __ ] life
up you are not I'm like like almost
shaky like just sweating but not
sweating and it's not hot and just
uncomfortable and then got up and was
walking around outside and your eyes
weren't working right yet and that's one
I've had a couple of those in like in
like I one of those in Fiji I had one of
those back in the States after coming
back from Vietnam where you just it's
like flying way too much and stay enough
weight as much and you're going on like
this
firing hot energy but then I think the
worst ones I've ever had were coming off
a coke anything i-i'll tell you this I
feel free to try coke but I will tell
you man the next day off a coke for me
is so unbearable I would never even toy
with the drug because I am shaky my
heart's racing it's skipping beats I am
having panic attacks I hear things were
super sensitive and I'm thinking why did
you do this for what so you could play
darts better yeah that's it so yeah
anytime New York I remember a time in
New York that after I got that I did
coke with a bunch of models over at
Jordan Rubens house Wow
and then I remember one time after Mardi
Gras coming back from Mardi Gras and the
drive back from Mardi Gras we have
brought an 8-ball home with us and but
you know you start panicking you're
driving through the south and the 90s
you if you found if you found a coat
back down you went to jail you went to
jail now I make it yeah you could get
killed back into that found coat yeah oh
yeah [ __ ] cut your head off and do
the coke right off your back right there
on the side of the road dude thank God
thank God that drugs out of my life they
used to sometimes they paint people
black and then [ __ ] kill him how
crazy is that
pretty crazy that's [ __ ] up man it's
an old Southern trade
what's the gold huh was it gold I'm not
sure black and uh I'm not sure what it
is I'm thinking has a name it's a legal
though I can't believe I even remembered
it we should kind of say it think about
that
it's called Yankee flip-flop I don't
know but it's definitely it's highly
illegal and it's wrong dude and it's
cultural appropriation about white
people too
yeah this is kind of [ __ ] up isn't it
yeah by definition what else we got hey
Theo von
this is a question for Burt Chrysler my
question is when he takes his shirt off
on stage that his signature trademark
like Ronnie Dangerfield I have no
respect because when I see him at the
Comedy Store on the regular it seems
like as soon as that shirt comes off the
energy level in the crowd his energy
level goes from like zero to 100 is
accurate do you think it does something
it's like a um it's so funny we were
talking about running run running danger
yet Rodney King he called him the caller
called him Ronnie Dangerfield's those nè
Dangerfield he also called number
Chrysler yeah this dude obviously
doesn't use all the vowels uh yeah with
the second I take my shirt off I started
taking my shirt off because I was I get
on the road and I just get depressed
yeah but if I took my shirt off it made
me giggle I just thought it was
ridiculous he's at 100% yeah so I took
my shirt off then one night I left it
off and I was like I'll [ __ ] it and then
I haven't started doing it all the time
he's take it off and leave it and it was
like it was like just funny and people
are like I remember people in the front
row bein like I can't believe your
shirts still off and I'd be like yeah I
know right
and then at the store sometimes I swear
to God if I won't I usually don't take
my shirt off in the o.r I won't take my
shirt off in the belly room but in the
main room if it's a big show and it's
sold out I do feel like there are people
that travel from around the world to
come to the store to see their favorite
comics and if I happen to be one of the
ones they wanted to see they definitely
want to see me with my shirt off and I
want them to have that experience yeah
it's like if you see Joe you see Joey
Diaz you want to hear him come out and
go like what's up [ __ ] yeah you
want to see a murder in the main room
right
then the ORF he's gonna [ __ ] around and
work on [ __ ] that's what the ORS for but
in the main room you want to see him
bring Thunder yeah and so yeah I wanna
take my shirt off
I definitely Rogan said to me last week
he was like man this hanging that shirt
comes off they lose their [ __ ] minds
yeah I was like I know it is crazy but I
think that energy that [ __ ] roar when
I
rip my shirt off definitely raises my
energy to write and I think I makes me
have more fun on stage do you feel like
it is but so because I like these days
I'll come out and like you know people
are pretty excited and stuff like that
and I'm like [ __ ] I don't know if I can
sustain this level of energy at the
beginning of the show take your shirt
off this is not gonna take my shirt off
I'm there and then ice and I feel caught
feel really I think it's because I
worked that way on the road so I feel
more comfortable and I'm like and I
don't feel like I'm in LA like I don't
feel like I have to be drama not in this
suit and so I just I've had some really
fun sets as of late at the store and but
they've all been shirtless even the ones
up in the belly room it's you shirt on
this fine if they're still funny [ __ ] do
you do you sense a special were you up
will you Yury robe you know no I don't
think so
I don't see it happening what I what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna get ripped I'm
gonna get [ __ ] ripped are you really
yeah no way good I don't think I can but
I'm gonna see how hooker lost weight a
night and I didn't like it I'm not gonna
lose weight to that point but I would
like to get just in shape enough where
where I wouldn't mind getting in shape
enough where people like all right time
to put a shirt on yeah I wouldn't mind
being there oh yeah but like I don't
know I don't know oh well maybe I'll
just never wear a shirt again would you
ever go completely nude one day you
think I've been asked to do that they
have a show like that I've been asked to
do that I thought about it in the sense
of just it would be so freeing to feel
completely exposed and then to see what
happens like when your brain knows that
you're not you know that there's nothing
else to hide kind of in a weird way I
like being naked I probably I probably
would enjoy that yeah anymore Nick that
came in and we're good let's do one more
and then I think we got to get him out
of here you got it
thanks so much for coming in today Bert
thank you and I appreciate ya supercool
is great I saw Michael Rosenbaum on here
oh yeah great owner he's a neat guy he's
a really great guy he's a really good
just had him on something's burnin what
am I gonna get you on something's burnin
I don't know that's a good question yes
seobeom what dude what's crack-a-lackin'
oh this is Brandon hopper from Wichita
Kansas bhop so I have a question for
Burt how was his experience on the hot
ones watch that too and uh yeah
McCracken ah that was a that I had been
a fan of that show for a long time yeah
I've Ben Whishaw no Evans will tell you
this I've been one of the first people
to find it and start sharing it with
everyone I loved it I loved that show
and that's cuz I'm in hip hop and hip
hop is all they had on there and I was
like oh shut the [ __ ] up Redman and so I
had known so much about it that going
into it I was it was almost a tabbed
anti-climactic so I was like like I was
just I was analyzing things too much but
Shonda such a great [ __ ] interview
like legit one of the his first question
was one of the best questions I've ever
been asked in my entire life and I was
like oh my god this is [ __ ] amazing
and I really felt like in those ten
questions he eats while you eat wings he
got some of the best answers I've ever
given anyone out of anyone mmm like and
he and I said [ __ ] up [ __ ] and he took
it out like he kept it out cuz I got at
one point when you eat that they do get
hotter when you get to the the bomb-ass
Kohli test or whatever the last the bomb
is just unbearable yeah and he's like
have you I think his question was have
you ever said anything you regretted on
podcasts and I said everything I'd ever
regretted because I couldn't think and I
as I'm saying and I'm like I'm
regretting this now I'm regretting it
again and he edited almost all over the
mountain Wow
yeah but that was a great that was a
really great experience and do right
after that I texted everyone like
everyone's gotta get on hot ones this
shows gonna blow up and I think everyone
was like you know what the internet it's
not the internet I want a TV show and
then I remember Tommy hit me up he's
like you know how can you get me on hot
ones my right when he did his last
special and I hit up Sean I was like
Sean this is Tom Tom because I knew
she'd go on yeah he did he did hot ones
and then the last question no and Tom's
was it was Bert if you could ask Tom any
question what would it be and my
question was how did he have any does he
make friends because he's so good at
making friends he's just so good and
then I wrote him and then Shawn said ask
him tell him why you're his friend and I
wrote this really heartfelt message to
Tom and Tom of course such a dick was
like yeah I still [ __ ] think he's in
there I know what I don't forget what he
said but he was still a slam on me but
yeah that shows amazing if you ever get
a chance man [ __ ] that shows so great
that in the new Jesus Miro is gonna be a
hot show to get on when they go to
Showtime holy [ __ ] man
those guys are that's well that's a fun
[ __ ] show I gotta watch that show and
something's burnin all things calm but
you gotta come check it out oh yeah I
want to get in and burn something yeah
come on dude I wouldn't mind making like
um do y'all do desserts and stuff is it
just like entrees we can do desserts we
could just do straight up desserts
because I don't like entrees as much as
I like desserts entrees yeah I think
entrees when you walk in the door you
talk about entrees
yeah dude entrees we're [ __ ] like
dessert some more bro right now I think
when I get a little older I could get
back to entrees again entrees yeah
ladies and gentlemen Theo von entree
ladies and gentlemen uh Bert Christ you
can see his new special secret time on
Netflix on Netflix starting September 28
September 24th September no no August
24th or 24th August 24th which is super
soon and then any time immediately after
that it'll be on right now so you can go
there right after this and check it out
Bert so much just thank you so much for
being around bro thank you brother you
know I love you Ben oh thank you man do
this do it again soon awesome all right
[Music]
these leaves I thought it's gonna take
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself on my
[Music]